Khloe Kardashian's fertility struggles
take front and center on this week's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians this is definitely not at
all how I thought this button was going
to go what if I can get right now in a
sneak peak from Sunday season finale
Khloe visits a fertility specialist with
Kim to discuss being a surrogate for her
sister in Kanye who want to have a third
child you have an awesome sister yeah
but the reality star receives some
unexpected news during an ultrasound
that makes her worry if she'll be able
to have children of her own
these are follicles these hold eggs
mm-hmm so this is just giving an idea of
how young your ovaries are okay are they
enrolled there are fewer follicles than
I anticipate for normal 32 year olds
[Music]
shut in another clip from the upcoming
episode chloe opens up to the doctor
about trying to get pregnant with her
ex-husband Lamar Odom I fake tried and I
was I was married but I knew the
circumstances weren't the healthiest so
I just kept pretending I was good
The Revenge body host gets candid about
her relationship with a former Lakers
star whom she married in 2009 after one
month of dating their divorce was
finalized in 2016 when I was doing my
fertility treatments like they were more
so for Lamar
I had to stop because there was much
deeper stuff that was happening in our
marriage
I knew you know it wasn't the right
situation to bring a child into
[Music]